[Music]
well good afternoon dear friends thank
you for joining us for
our program i'd like to know this is a
live q and a program which airs
every tuesday at 4 30 in the afternoon
we have a half hour program we probably
need to extend that because i have a
pile of questions
probably two inches thick on my desk
but we still haven't been able to extend
the program but maybe in the future we
will i have with me
my good friend and fellow laborer c.a
murray
who is the associate speaker for secrets
unsealed among many other things
he's been a great blessing to the
ministry and um
we want to begin with the word of prayer
as we always do
so i'm going to ask ca to please have a
word of prayer for us my pleasure to do
so shall we pray
father god again we praise you and thank
you for the power of your word
we thank you that there is power not
only in hearing the word and reading the
word but putting it into practice
and that our lives can be enriched we
can be inspired
we can be given strength and direction
as we seek to serve you faithfully
we ask us now lord that you would be
with us as we go into your word and
try to answer these questions because we
know that spiritual things are
spiritually discerned
amen we want to know your will to
discern your will to understand your
will
and to do your will so embolden us and
enable us
to serve you faithfully and we praise
you and thank you in the worthy and
blessed name of jesus
amen and amen amen i just wanted to
remind you that if you want to send us
your questions
you can do so electronically at the
following address
tv at some tv dot org you'll see it on
the screen tv
at some tv dot org and we'll be glad to
get your questions do the research
and if there's an answer we will do our
best to find it
so we have a very interesting question
here ca
which appears now and then um
and this is what it says i'd like to
know about the sixth commandment
people legally kill others in war i
don't know about legally killing people
in war
and through capital punishment isn't
this
breaking the commandment about killing a
family who isn't a believer struggles
with this kind of question
and i don't have a satisfying answer
for him so what can we say about
this particular question well you know
we have a textbook i'm going to refer to
in just a little bit but
um there are those who are conscientious
objectors who don't believe in murder or
killing
and at any time in any case uh under any
circumstances
but the bible does say those who spill
blood
uh by them their blood shall be spilled
it is
it is it is the prerogative of the
government to set rules and laws
for the order the regulation of society
and um
there are certain crimes certain things
that happen that have to be dealt with
with uh manhattan's discernment capital
punishment
the the the text that we we often quote
thou shalt now kill really means thou
shalt not
murder uh and there's a little
difference between killing and murder
murder
talks about the unwarranted taking of a
life
uh and and that's what the
that is where the prohibition lies um
you get mad you take a life you get
upset you take a life you plan to take a
life
that of course is against the
commandments of god but certain times i
believe
when when uh the government in the
regulation of its citizens and society
is uh given powers to
to deal with uh life and death issues
uh and so we we find that but that is
not that's not
murder i don't believe it's not murder
as uh as stipulated by the word of god
you said you were going to read a text
ah
genesis 9 i'm going to hold you to it
well i think i said we were going to
read a text we meaning you
let's do it in unison
i'm opening my bible to it here um
genesis 9 verse 6 genesis 9 verse 6.
very important verse
indeed it is you know i have a this is a
fairly new bible
and the pages stick together uh i got
one with
really really big print so that uh my
fading eyes can see it generally
9 6. that's the text i was referring to
whoever sheds man's blood by man
his blood shall be shed for in the image
of god
he made man that's a pretty clear text
it is it is a pretty a pretty clear text
you know the
i i during the vietnam war i was
draft age and luckily i uh because of my
bad eyes and
we both have one eyes and we share that
uh
well we share a lot of things yeah too
i was rejected i could not i couldn't
serve
but we had many people in our church who
were conscientious objectors
who did not believe of course you know
about desmond dawson the most famous
possibly adventist conscientious
objector who did not believe in taking
life at any
for any reason or any cause and and they
wanted to serve their country
but they also did not want to um to take
to take lives
so i i can understand that and respect
that a very good friend of mine junior
roosevelt dockery jr uh died in vietnam
uh he was a medic he didn't want to take
lives but this sort of gives
a person who takes life um
uh puts himself in line to be judged and
and to have their life taken
right you know i remember
in the 60s uh when the vietnam war was
going on
that the seventh adventist church
established what is known as the medical
cadet corps yes
mccs do you remember that i do i belong
to them for a while
at wisconsin academy and basically the
idea was to prepare
young men because men at that time
served in the military
uh to be able to serve as medics in the
armed forces
and uh so you know i personally
am a conscientious objector
you know i would have no i never served
in the military but i would have no
reservations
about serving in the military as long as
i could serve to save
life rather than to take life yes
yes yes you know we we have the the the
the
biblical prohibition eye for eye tooth
for tooth
uh people say well that means you got to
take an eye for an eye
if someone kills something of yours you
got to kill something in there
and that's not really what the text is
saying um
back in the times in biblical times
people were taking a life for
anything it's saying uh
only eye for eye only truth for truth
not that you have to
but don't if if i steal your cow
don't kill me you know don't don't let
the punishment fit the crime don't don't
everything doesn't have to be i'm going
to take your life or i'm going to take
the life of somebody in your family but
match the
severity of the punishment with the
severity of the of the crime
and don't go overboard because life is
prescient right and then the bible says
precious
in the sight of the lord is the death of
his saints so
god is very very uh concerned about how
we treat one another
uh only eye for eye only truth for truth
not just eye for eye and
death for everything that happens it's a
very uh important text and very
important way to look at it
yeah you know some people have an issue
with
for example the the flood you know how
god could drown
the whole antediluvian world or how he
could destroy sodom and gomorrah with
fire
however god is the creator
and god knows when a civilization or
when a city
has gone beyond the point of no return
in other words it's similar to capital
punishment an individual who has gone to
the point where
where there's no repentance and there's
no possibility of change
um then you know the the state
has the sword like it says in romans
chapter 13
yes yes but you know god can do what man
can't do when it comes to civilizations
and of course the nations
when it comes to cities god is the
creator
um first john for a very familiar text
he that loveth not knoweth not
no it's not god for god is love we start
with the premise
that god is a god of love and a god of
life
um and he wants to preserve love
and life and christ came to give us
everlasting life
so god is about you living and loving
not you hating and dying but there are
times when
civilizations individuals have put
themselves
in places where they are beyond or
outside of the protection the love of
god
and at that point god as creator
has the right dare i say to to to end
life
but really only god if you want to talk
about rights
only god has that right uh because he
can create and
uh another thing um this is kind of an
ontological look at it but the idea is
we do anything for life there is
something in us that that that wants to
hold on to life
at all cause but this world
is not the end of all things
uh and remaining in this world is not
the end of all things
i i would like to live just as long as i
am of value
to the kingdom of god amen but
i would trade
whatever time i have left for eternity
so if god said okay
murray tomorrow your soul is going to be
required
your labors have come to an end but
heaven is waiting for you
right i'm fine with that i have no
problem with that amen
you know i'm not trying to stay here
just to stay here
as long as i'm of service to god i will
stay amen but if god says
your service is over heaven is waiting
i'm good with that
you know another very important point
when it comes to god
is the fact that god never destroys a
city
a civilization or a nation
until that person has gone beyond the
point of no return
you know and he always gives great light
before destruction yes he sent no 120
years
yes well said lot in the cities abraham
you know in the cities of sodom and
gomorrah um you know what more light
could belshazzar have had
the the night that babylon fell yeah so
so god and at the end of time the loud
cry
the angel that fills the whole earth
with the glory of god and then of course
the plagues fall on babylon because
babylon is
irreversible so only god knows when
a person a nation a city has gone beyond
the point of no return
which means that if god allowed them to
continue living
they would not repent and they would not
change their way well said and
and lord does not do things in a huff or
rashly or capriciously god
takes his time he weighs and
he meters and he uses the best solution
for that time for that situation we
don't serve a tit for tag
you hit me i'm going to hit you you
steal my call i steal your cat no it's
not that kind of nonsense
uh god meters and he always works
through love
amen one of the things we will see
during the thousand years
is that those actions that god took were
for the best
of the situations and for the best of
the individuals involved in those
situations
and the destruction of the wicked is an
act of love yes sir
because because god has to cleanse the
universe
of individuals who would have never
repented
had god given them 10 lifetimes yes
so so god is going to cleanse the
universe so that those
who walked with the lord who repented of
their sins confess their sins
trusted in jesus will be able to live in
the universe where there's no sin and no
strife
and no crying out well said i have had
bible studies
at length with some individuals who
simply did not want to hear anything
about the lord
and of course ellen white says if they
want to hear there's plenty evidence to
hear and to know
if they don't there's not enough text in
the bible to get them to change their
minds i've had individuals and
and i don't know when i was done maybe
something else happened to change their
minds but when i left them
they were totally shut up shut off
against god
didn't want to hear it didn't want to
accept it everything i could bring from
the word of god they had an answer for
sometimes
because many times not uh so
all you can do is leave them and commend
them to the lord there may be a change
they may not
but if there is no change it would be
counterfeit it would be wrong for the
lord
to take that person to heaven because
they would not be happy they would not
be
satisfied and they would despoil the
beauty of the heavenly experience
because for them
heaven would be hell and god gave them
an opportunity yes that's the key
if god had not given them an opportunity
then god would not be just
true but everyone who is lost will have
had
somehow yes an opportunity to repent and
confess their sins and trust in jesus
okay now here we have another question
if sabbath is such an important issue
why has god not
has god not delegated
says delegate but delegated this
critically important message to martin
luther
john calvin or wesley's i
am a re-baptized adventist i have no
reason to doubt
the legitimacy of the lord's sabbath i
just wonder why
didn't the early reformers of the
churches realize the importance of the
sabbath looking forward to your answers
to my question so
you know are there going to be people in
heaven who didn't keep the sabbath
that's the big question
well let's look look at the question um
the reformers each
you know we tend to look at the
reformers through star
cross glasses the reformers didn't have
it all
when you look at what they were coming
out of they did well to get as far as
they did
given what they were fighting luther
didn't have it all loose it was not
a perfect individual we found out later
in his life looser had some very uh
anti-semitic thoughts so they weren't
perfect individuals but god used them
to start a movement that um
grew over the centuries the reformers
didn't have it all but they
they were the ones who got it started
and then there were others who came
behind them and
increased light came um but the sabbath
was there for their understanding and
during those dark ages god always had a
people
who were keeping the sabbath right so
the light of the sabbath never went out
it excuse me burned dimly for a while
but it never went out and the reformers
didn't have it all but someone had to
get it started someone had to light the
match
and god used these individuals the
luthers and the
the zwinglis and the the list is almost
without end
of individuals to get it started and to
start that flame burning
yeah you know you'd have to take into
account
the historical context in which luther
calvin
and you know swingly worked
they were dealing with a situation where
the church was extremely
legalistic oh yes in other words you
could work your way to heaven
you know by lighting candles and by
praying the rosary
and and by doing pilgrimages you know
you can actually earn salvation
yes so god raised up luther and calvin
and swingly
for a specific purpose and that was to
restore
righteousness by faith yes that you are
not
saved by your works you are saved by
grace through faith yes
in order to work yeah and so god only
expected them
to do the the work at that particular
moment that needed to be restored yes
yes now when it comes to the end of time
you know in 1844 the most holy place
opened and it's interesting that our the
pioneers
shortly after scene that jesus moved
into the most holy place
because the ark is in the most holy
place they said now wait a minute
the ark on earth was a shadow of the
heavenly ark
in the earthly ark where the ten
commandments so the ten commandments
must be in the heavenly ark
also and the sabbath uh was in the
earthly ark so the sabbath might must
still be
in the ark in heaven so the sabbath must
still be binding
so at that point when god's people enter
the most holy place
they suddenly see the significance of
the sabbath yes in other words the
sabbath becomes present truth
at each stage god has a present truth
yes you know when
when jesus came to this earth the
present truth was that the messiah had
been born
when he was baptized the present truth
was that the messiah had come to perform
his ministry
when jesus died the present truth was
announcing his death yes
when jesus resurrected well what did
those who resurrected with him what did
they do
well they announced that he resurrected
yes and then when he went to heaven
peter preaches you know he's been
installed as a high priest
1844 what they did now so the hour of
judgment has come
so god has a present truth at each stage
in history
and he expects those who live in that
period to deal with that specific
subject at that specific time
you know if you look at the burden of
the reformation and and i
i really appreciate your your
perspective here the
idea that the christ
our high priest christ our savior had
been buried
under centuries of
of spiritual dirt dare i say to unearth
that just to get us back to jesus as
lord and savior righteousness by faith
that christ is at the head of this thing
the center of this thing
was was really a major accomplishment
given the times in which uh these
reformers found themselves
so uh you they ought to be applauded
just for getting
christ back on the throne where he
belongs amen right and then these other
things would come
but we didn't even know who jesus was
because
the the love of christ the work of
christ uh had been
lost for so many years that's what was
called the dark ages
because the light had gone out on the
work of christ even who christ was
so they they did a fine job just just
putting christ back
on the throne and bringing him to the
center from the periphery or actually
being buried
under centuries of of chaos and and and
misunderstanding right of who jesus was
yeah and luther was not always
consistent when it came to the sabbath
either you know some
some of the places in his writing say
that you know the papacy claims that
sunday's the day but the day of sabbath
in other places he says that sunday is
the day so
martin luther was not a systematic
theologian yes
john calvin was what he's a systematic
theologian yes you can tell by his
volumes the institutes of the christian
religion
but anyway and i'm going to skip the
next couple of questions because they're
too long for the time that we have
so i'm going to go to this one and this
one actually is quite simple to answer
because the bible tells us
uh dear pastor boer and it says pastor
governor gover isn't with us here so
ca is it true that the earth will be the
new headquarters of the universe
in revelation 21 22 it seems to say that
since the lord god almighty and the lamb
will be in the new jerusalem which will
come down to earth
what will happen to the present heaven
where god
jesus and his angels live
so will this be the capital of the
universe that's one question
and the other question is what's going
to happen with the place where god lives
now
well we know that some very exciting
things are going to happen
before the final judgment is is executed
and after the thousand years
some wonderful things are going to
happen i'm trying to
get to revelation here we go okay
um
which one are you looking for um i want
to read the
uh revelation 21 22 and beyond
a little before and beyond and right
here
my pages are sticking together let me
read this while you're looking
thank you uh revelation 22
we know that the new jerusalem let me
put it this way before i read the verses
we know that the new jerusalem is going
to descend from heaven
after the thousand years and it's going
to rest
upon the mount of olives that has been
split and opened into a large plane
true so the jerusalem the new jerusalem
is the capital of god in heaven
we know that because it says in hebrews
chapter
11 that the great heroes of the old
testament look for
a city whose builder and maker is god is
god correct so we know that the new
jerusalem
which is in heaven now is going to
descend to the earth
and uh do we know whether the god and
jesus jesus says god too but obviously
the father and the son
are going to live here on this earth yes
revelation 22 verse 2 says
in the middle of its street that is of
the city and on either side of the river
was the tree of life
which bore 12 fruits fruits each tree
yielding its fruit
every month the leaves are for the of
the tree were for the healing of the
nations
and there shall be no more curse but the
throne of god
and of the lamb shall be in it and his
servants shall
serve him they shall see his face and
his name shall be on their forehead
and then it speaks about the city there
shall be no night there
they need no lamp nor light of the sun
for the lord god gives them light
and they shall reign forever and ever so
it says the throne
of god and of the lamb is going to be in
the city
and the city is going to be unpleasant
it's going to be here yeah yeah the city
is going to be here
so the capital of the universe then is
transferred
uh from where it is now to this earth
and and what a
what a heady thought what a marvelous
thought
that god so loved the world that he
makes his capital now
here this little ball this little spec
uh among the millions and billions of
planets and
all the things that god has created uh
will now be the the capital
of the universe yeah yeah what's going
to happen with the place where god
abided in heaven well
it's not going to be there anymore if
he's going to transfer
everything here it must mean that
that there's not going to be any
anything up there anymore
you know god god is not stuck to any
place what
what what is heaven well heaven is where
god is
and if if he brings it here this is
heaven you know it's it's right it's
where it's where he is and i want to be
where he is
and if he's going to be here that's
precisely where i want to be
you know the amazing thing to me as i
think about this
is that this atom of a world
i guess we couldn't even call it an atom
is less than an atom
this atom of a world in the vast
universe which appears to be limitless
yes i mean billions and billions of
light years
and they keep on seeing further and
further as the telescopes are invented
yes that god is going to make this
little
redeemed rebellious world formerly
rebellious world
that he is going to make this the
capital of the universe throughout
eternity
and he's going to dwell with us with the
redeemed
you know that is a mind-boggling thought
it is it's very humbling and the fact
that he's also going to retain
vestiges of his self suffering here
throughout all eternity
all the eternity it's it's a humbling
thing
to know that god values us so much
that these kinds of changes are going to
be made for eternity
yeah yeah you know when you read about
the ascension of christ
it says that he was caught up in a cloud
and ellen white adds that
as she ascended to heaven the disciples
were gazing in fact acts
uses the word gazing why stand ye gazing
into heaven
so they're gazing into heaven you know
at this jesus
whom they have spent three and a half
years with they couldn't conceive even
of a second
yes living without jesus yes and so now
jesus disappears in the sky he's gone
but they remember that jesus said has
said i will come again
and receive you to myself yes when you
finish preaching the gospel to the world
and so what do this motivates them to
say we need to
hurry this up so that jesus can come
soon
so the motive the great motive for
evangelism
is the second coming of christ as far as
the apostles yes
and us are concerned yeah that they may
be with him even as the father
and the son are together uh it's not
complete until we're all together
yeah yeah and uh that you know ellen
white says that heaven is christ
heaven is jesus precisely wherever jesus
is that's where heaven is that's heaven
that's heaven
and even if there was not a street of
gold even if there was not foundations
of precious stones even if there was no
uh pearly gates even if there was no
tree of life with
12 fruits one different everyone every
month it would be worth being there
if there was nothing none of the fringe
benefits
if it was only jesus that was there and
the father yes
it would make it all worthwhile yes
every now and again we have a little
celebration we have a little cake and
maybe sometimes a little tiny bit of ice
cream
not something we do regularly certainly
not every day uh these other things
are the the cherry on the sunday pastor
yeah
jesus is is the goal but uh god says
along with that
got some other little nice little things
that i'm going to kick in there also
yeah but heaven is jesus
that's well said yeah jesus jesus
is the main course and all of these
fringe benefits are the dessert
we might say amen and amen well time is
just about up i guess we need to
conclude the program
so you want to do that ca my pleasure
uh again we we thank you for your
questions uh
get your questions as you can see we
have fun studying the word of god we
enjoy doing it
and hopefully you are having not only
fun
but that you're inspired and impressed
by the holy spirit as we together mind
these things that help us
walk each day as we come closer to the
coming of our lord and savior jesus
christ keep on studying
send in your questions and we'll see you
again next time god bless
[Music]
you